sie müssen sich einiges anhören und
allerhand gefallen lassen
großbritanniens unerschütterliche
umweltaktivisten
geht von der straße runter ich muss mein
kind zur schule bringen und zur arbeit
schreibt diese frau aufgebracht
und dann wird es richtig ruppig und
bleibt nichts anderes übrig denn die
regierung reagiert nur auf solche
störungen es tut uns unendlich leid für
die leute es ist tragisch aber wir haben
keine andere wahl
seit wochen legen knapp 150
umweltschützer mit ihren sitzblockaden
in london und den südosten englands den
verkehr lahm
sogar auf autobahn
sie sind der überzeugung dass nur noch
radikaler ziviler ungehorsam helfen kann
ihn zu retten ist eine absplitterung der
bewegung extinction rebellion ihre
forderung die regierung soll bis 2030
großbritanniens notorisch schlecht
wärmegedämmten häusern isolieren dafür
lassen sie sich von wütenden pendlern
und polizisten von der straße tragen
es tut mir so leid aber wir tun es für
die kinder
und wie reagiert die regierung des
landes das die weltklimakonferenz in
diesem jahr ausrichtet mit untrüglichem
gespür für den wachsenden unmut im volk
wir fühlen uns der arbeitenden
bevölkerung und der oft schweigende
mehrheit verpflichtet daher werde ich es
nicht tolerieren dass diese sogenannten
öko krieger auf unserer lebensweise
herumtrampeln und die zeit unserer
polizei verschwendet
sagt die sich gerne unerbittlich geben
die innenministerin auf dem parteitag
der konservativen und kündigt härtere
maßnahmen an um den protestierenden
beizukommen recht und ordnung statt
isolieren
mitte oktober beschließt installiert
briten dann die proteste für einige tage
auszusetzen
im namen der gruppe überbringt aktivist
betriebstor in der downing street ein
brief für den premierminister
darin wird boris johnson aufgefordert
die zeit zu nutzen um noch einmal in
sich zu gehen und über die forderung
nachzudenken
auch bis kann die verschnaufpause gut
gebrauchen denn sie ständigen
beschimpfungen auszusetzen kostet kraft
erklärte uns am ufer des flüsschens tour
in der grafschaft kent
als unbezahlter flussfahrt schützt er
hier die natur ist er für einen
viereinhalb kilometer langen streifen
zuständig
ich bin wahrscheinlich 15 bis 20 mal von
der straße gezerrt worden wir glauben
leidenschaftlich an gewaltlosigkeit und
betreiben zivilen ungehorsam so wie er
sein soll ohne auf beleidigung zu
reagieren es hat etwas pathetisch du
sitzt da und denkst ihr könnt mit mir
machen was ihr wollt ihr könnt mir
wehtun nicht wegziehen ich tue das
richtige
die roten linien auf den dokumenten bei
ihm zu hause zeigen die orte an denen er
bei einer blockade von der polizei
aufgegriffen wurde sollte ihm das dort
noch mal passieren muss er ins gefängnis
wir werden als alte ökos verschrieb das
sind tatsächlich viele ältere dabei weil
wir ein schlechtes gewissen haben
aufgrund des lebensstils den wir
genießen konnten mit viel reisen und
konsumieren ich liebe mein haus aber
wenn ich es verliere weil sie mich
einsperren bitte komm doch und hol mich
politiker tel wir geben nicht auf
niemand würde bestreiten dass befund
insel retten einen wichtigen punkt haben
großbritannien hat ein riesiges problem
mit schlecht isolierten häusern
das liegt nicht nur an viel alte
bausubstanz wie hier im idyllischen
hellgate in yorkshire oder so manche
bausünde aus den 60ern
selbst bei neubauten hapert es
paul buck in ist energieberater und
führt uns in ein haus in einem
neubaugebiet am rande der stadt bis vor
kurzem lebte hier eine ältere dame doch
kaum hatte sie ihr über 700.000 euro
teures traumhaus bezogen sie wieder aus
der grund schlechte isolierung wie
polens mit einer wärmebildkamera
demonstriert
sie sagte in der nacht fühle es sich so
an als würde jemand kalte luft über
ihrem kopf gießen überall hier ist nicht
abgedichtet da ist ein gewaltiger
luftstrom hinter der wand und er zieht
all die wärme aus dem gebäude
doch was schlecht ist bei der
wärmedämmung hat oft auch gravierende
auswirkungen auf den brandschutz am ende
schließt die 82 jährige nur noch mit
einer feuerschutz decke neben ihrem bett
unten in der küche erzeugt pauls kollege
künstlichen rauch in einem vernünftig
abgedichteten haus dürfte es nicht
passieren dass der rauch ins
schlafzimmer zieht
mit hilfe von pauls expertise versucht
die besitzerin das bauunternehmen per
klage zum rückkauf zu zwingen doch
kritische baufirmen sind mächtig
leider ist dies hier kein einzelfall ich
erlebe das überall im land ich bin
inzwischen so etwas wie ein seelsorger
die leute rufen mich in tränen an weil
sie oft wissen wie sie mit den
schwierigkeiten in ihren häusern fertig
werden soll
teil des problems ist dass im königreich
akuter wohnungsmangel herrscht der ließe
sich mit strengen auflagen in sachen
energieeffizienz nicht beheben
argumentieren die großen bauunternehmen
die folge sind niedrige standards und
hohe gewinne für die firmen bekannt ist
in diesem zusammenhang dass ein viertel
aller parteispenden an die regierende
konservative partei aus dem bausektor
kommen
bauen bauen bauen besser grüner und
schneller boris johnson
alles leere worte meint
umweltaktivist jetzt kurz vor der
klimakonferenz sind er und die anderen
wieder auf der straße
in londons finanzdistrikt clip bis seine
hand auf eine kreuzung
die polizei rückt mit ihrem klebstoff
entfernungs köfferchen an
dank der abgeführt und auf die wache
gefahren
sie werden es immer wieder versuchen bis
zum beginn des klimagipfels
und noch lange darüber hinaus
[Musik]